Are you
Hey
darling.
Hallelujah.
The title of tonight's lecture is hidden
agendas because that's exactly what this
is about. It's about hidden agendas.
In the previous lectures, we spoke about
the origin of secret societies and how
they are controlled.
And we saw that they originate from
Babylon
which gave rise to cababalism and also
to Islamic secret societies, the
Ismiles, the Katites, the Fatimmites,
the Duisers and the Assassins, which we
haven't dealt with as such. Out of
cabalism eventually camenosticism
which replaces Jesus Christ with a
universal messiah who today is called
the cosmic Christ. And this cosmic
Christ has none of the attributes of the
Jesus Christ of the Bible. But in order
to make him acceptable to the world,
everybody will have to accept him. That
means Jesus Christ even amongst
Christians will have to be brought lower
to a level of this cosmic Christ to
accommodate all others who want to be
his equal.
According to Elifas Levi,nosticism
was founded by Simon Magus who was a
sorcerer and put on a cloak of
Christianity. He was the one who had
himself baptized but he was rebuked by
Peter for wanting to buy the Holy
Spirit.
So a cloak of Christianity
covered nasticism.
Out of this philosophy, eventually it
became formalized
and the Knights Templars within a large
religious system were the harborers of
the ancient philosophy. In other words,
they were the harborers of the secret
ofnosticism.
They had very close ties with uh the
Islamic societies
and eventually we saw that the Knights
Templars were suppressed by the king of
France. Many of them escaped however to
Spain where the king in Spain gave them
his protection and they flourished
further and their rights and rituals and
degrees were perpetuated in subsequent
organizations. So the Templars ne never
really died other than in name.
The Templar secret knowledge was kept
alive in an inner circle in
Rosacrruianism
and overseen by the Jesuit order. The
Jesuit order then created Freemasonry as
we saw on Sunday. And uh Freemasonry
is the so-called Protestant arm if you
like although it's not only a Protestant
arm. It is a international arm to bring
about those changes which are necessary
to set up this dark kingdom. So tonight
we're going to have a look at
Freemasonry and look behind the scenes
as to what it really entails because
most Freemasons like in all secret
societies are fully unaware of what
happens behind the scenes.
You will remember that Gary H. Carr in
his work on route to global occupation
gave a very similar uh expose. He also
takes it through cabalism, gnosticism to
the Knights Templars. Then he misses out
on the the Jesuit connection which is
the military powerful arm controlling
all these things. And he has Freemasonry
control Marxism, American European
secret political societies,
international banking elite, and then
scarily the World Council of Churches.
Now, this is not me saying this. This is
this man and he is uh no small fish. and
uh theosophical societies together with
many cults then constitute what is known
as the new age movement and the new age
movement is much larger than what we
believe just to be uh a few esoterics
doing their thing. It culminates in an
entire system which is to unite the
entire world and the world council of
churches will play a very prominent role
in this mechanism. So it's very
important that we know what freemasonry
stands for. The outer shell of
freemasonry proposes to sell whatever
religion is prominent in that area. So
for example, if you are living in a
Muslim country and you belong to
Freemasonry, then the religion that is
propagated at the level of the people
and at the level the lower level of
Freemasonry will be Islam. If you are
living in a Jewish environment, then of
course the religion will be Judaism. If
you are living in a Christian
environment environment then the Bible
will be the central book in a lodge and
as far as the lower echelon of the
members is concerned Christianity will
be the basis for the movement. But in
actual fact if it is controlled by an
another power inside then the picture
can be totally different.
Now I'm going to quote tonight from the
very very best sources. I'm not going to
use any hearsay. I'm not going to use
thus said so and so and so and so about
so and so through so and so. No, we're
going to go to the original sources the
very best. The book morals and dogma is
a book written by Albert Pike. is
considered the central theology of
Freemasonry.
Only the highest Freemasons receive this
book and upon their death this book must
be returned to the lodge. So this is not
something that is readily available.
Today you can go on the internet and you
can order morals and dogma but you will
never receive the real McCoy
unless you by chance happen to find
someone where a freemason has died and
the book had never been returned and
after a few generations somebody finds
it and some of these copies are actually
floating around and uh there you can
find the original information. In my own
case, I have many documents because my
father-in-law was very very high up in
these issues and when he died, I
obtained a fair amount of information
that would probably not be available to
most people. And uh in my researches for
many many years, I searched for the
original documents so that we can have
it out of the horse's mouth. So if you
feel upset about what I am saying
tonight, remember I will be saying
nothing. I will be quoting and then you
make your own minds up as to whether
this is so or whether this is not so.
Morals and dogma, the very highest
source in Freemasonry.
Page 870. The Templars, like all other
secret orders and associations, had two
doctrines.
One concealed and reserved for the
masters, which was Johannesm,
the other public, which was the Roman
Catholic. It's quite straightforward.
So there is a doctrine that is being
taught to the masses and the masses are
the uninitiated. Markx called them
cattle. They are also called
katakumans.
They are called goyam. They are called
all kinds of derogatory names.
Now if the outer shell, the teaching of
the templars to the people
was Catholicism,
they also of course adopted a very pious
garb and pretended this was the crux of
their religion. But on the inside they
had another religion. And the order that
they ascribed to is Johannism.
Now we have many orders of St. John
today. Many orders. Well, just think
about some of the large organizations.
We have cathedrals to St. John where
some very strange things happen as we
will see as we go along over time. We
have St. John's ambulance for example.
You know, we could go on and on and on
and on, but I don't want to go into too
much detail here. All of these are
organizations which are philanthropic.
Seem to be doing a very good thing. They
run many many hospitals. They give huge
sums of money to the poor and to the to
the
well whatever to children's hospitals to
the crippled people in the world. And
being so philanthropic, it is very hard
to pin something negative to
organizations that appear to do some so
much good. And this is actually the best
cloak into which to clothe something
else that should not be discovered. So
whenever you see yanism
supposedly of course from John the
Baptist
then eye it with suspicion. So two
doctrines one to the outside and one to
the inside.
Morals and dogma page 820. The Templars
were gravely accused of spitting upon
Christ and denying God at their
receptions of gross obscinities,
conversations with female devils and the
worship of monstrous idol. Now we
discussed that in the previous lecture.
The end of the drama is well known and
how Jacques Demal and his fellows
perished in the flames. But now this is
the highest source of Freemasonry.
But before his execution, the chief of
the doomed order organized and
instituted what afterwards came to be
called the occult, hermetic or Scottish
masonry. You cannot get a higher source
than this. So according to Albert Pike,
Freemasonry continued the legacy of the
Templars.
In the gloom of his prison, the
Grandmaster created four metropolitan
lodges. At Naples for the east, at
Edinburg for the west, at Stockholm for
the north, and at Paris for the south.
The initials of his name, JBM, found in
the same order in the first three
degrees, are but one of the many
internal and cognant proofs that such
was the origin of modern Freemasonry.
That's from the horse's mouth. So the
Templars aren't really dead but still
alive. In fact, in the York right there
is a a level which is the Templar level.
So everything is there.
The 32nd degree of masonry, sublime
prince of the royal secret. That's the
highest level of Scottish Freemasonry.
There is one higher degree, the 33rd
degree, but that is an honorary degree.
So the highest level of Freemasonry is
the 32nd. And again, morals and dogma.
The occult science of the ancient margi
was concealed under the shadows of the
ancient mysteries. It was imperfectly
revealed or rather disfigured by the
Gnostics. They don't show the whole
picture. It was guessed at under the
obscurities that covered the pretended
crimes of the Templars. And it is found
enveloped in enigmas that seem
impenetrable in the rights of the
highest masonry. Do you have that? So
out of the horse's mouth, the mystery of
the ancient Maggi
and the uh shadows of the ancient
mysteries are present and known to the
highest levels of Freemasonry.
None of the lower levels know anything
about this. They come into the lodge and
they think it is
a Christian society with well at least
with Christian flavor if they're in the
Christian lodge and that they are a
brotherhood for doing good unto others.
Well, this is San Salvador. This is in
Mayorca where the Templars of course
found protection under the Spanish
kings. And uh if you go into the templar
enclave, you will find on the altars of
the churches. Remember that the templars
were a order of the Roman Catholic
Church like the Jesuits are today. The
most powerful order within the church.
So they were the most powerful order in
the church that controlled not only the
military aspects because they were
knights, but they also controlled the
financial aspects. And the double-headed
eagle was part and parcel of their
symbolism. Two heads. Yanos had two
heads. He looked forwards and he looked
backwards.
If you go into the other churches, you
will find them on the altars. There it
is above the altar of the churches on
Mayora. Now, this is rose accusianism.
The rose is a symbol of their deity.
Now, I really don't get too upset about
symbols. If I had to be upset about
every symbol, I would have to throw
everything out of my house or anything
that is manufactured because they all
have the symbols on them. We are living
in this world, but we don't have to be
part of this world. And we can do things
whether there's a symbol on or not
because obviously a symbol means
nothing. But it's just interesting to
know. It's like reading another
language.
Well, here are some of the occult
teachings of rosacrruianism
where you have the ziferats, the levels
that you can attain to. And this is pure
cabalism. Now, you must understand that
in the cabala, it is not Yave who is the
true ruler. It is Lucifer who is the
true ruler. But we will come to that as
we come later. and the ziferats are
emanations of his uh appearance. So
let's ask morals and dogma again what it
has to say about the cabala which by the
way is called the most holy cabala
today. The talmut is called the holy
talmut and the bible is just called the
tra. Isn't that strange? The Bible is
called the Torah. And then a book of
rules that never appear in the Bible is
called the Holy Talmud. And an occult
book is called the most holy Cabala. And
I would like to venture so far as that
there are very very few rabbis in the
world today that are not cababalists,
which is scary.
The holy cabala or tradition of the
children of Set, this is of course not
true. according to this doctrine then
set would have been an apostate already
or they turn it around they say not an
apostate an initiate so there's an
internal doctrine for the initiate and a
public doctrine for the goyam for the
cattle just to keep them occupied
tradition of the children of set was
carried from calalda by Abraham taught
to the Egyptian priesthood by Joseph
recovered and purified by Moses
concealed under symbols in the Bible
revealed by the savior to St. John.
There you have it again, the
Johanssonites and contained entire under
hieratic figures analogous to those that
all tookity in the apocalypse of that
apostle. Okay. So now he's turned
everything around. Abraham, Joseph,
Moses were all initiates and what they
taught to the people was
dril. Let's put it that way. to keep
them happy and to keep them uninformed.
But on the inside, they had another
doctrine. Now, that's of of course not
true because Moses wrote the Torah and
everything they believe is the opposite
of what the Torah teaches. And the
Cababala,
that book turns the Torah upside down
and makes it occult.
The three great lights of the lodge are
symbols to us of the power, wisdom and
beneficence of the deity. They are also
symbols of the first three cifpherots
emanations of this deity according to
the cabala. So the cabala is very very
central in this uh story. We read on
every Masonic lodge is a temple of
religion. Although they are told that it
is not a temple of religion, here morals
and dogma says it is a temple of
religion and its teachings are
instructions in religion. This is true
religion revealed to the ancient
patriarchs. Now we've seen that they've
turned the ancient patriarchs upside
down into occultists in order to sell
this to the people of course which
masonry has taught for many centuries
and which it will continue to teach as
long as time endures.
Okay, thank you.
Let's ask some questions and we'll ask
masonry to answer it. And the sources we
will use are only the highest Masonic
writings and the the Freemasons that
will be uh asked to give answers will be
of only the very highest degree. So
Albert Mackey he wrote the encyclopedia
of Freemasonry. You cannot get a better
source than that. Most of the best
lodges, the greatest lodges have the
encyclopedia of Freemasonry. and he was
a 33deree Freemason which means he was
an initiate.
Is Freemasonry a Christian organization?
If Freemasonry was simply a Christian
institution, the Jew, the Muslim, the
Brahman, the Buddhist could not
conscientiously partake of its
illumination. So it's not a Christian
institution. So why is the Bible there?
It's there as a symbol as we saw of the
first three cifpherats.
Is it Christian? Freemasonry is not
Christian nor a substitute for it. Well,
what is it then?
Morals and dogma
rejecting all the wild and useless
speculations of the Zenavvesta, the
cabala, the Gnostics and the schools of
the religion and philosophy of masonry.
You cannot get it plainer than that.
So in other words, the cabala is the
religion of masonry. But the cabala is
used in such a way that the people
believe that what they believe is what's
in the Bible.
Masonry is a search light. The search
leads us directly back, as you can see,
to the Cabala. In that ancient little
understood medley of absurdity and
philosophy, the initiate will find the
source of many doctrines.
All truly dogmatic religions that
includes Islam, Buddhism, Hinduism, all
of them have issued from the Cabala
and return to it everything scientific
and grand and the religious dreams of
all the Illuminati, the ones that are
illuminated. This is Luciferian
language. Jacob Burma, Swedenborg, St.
Martin and others is borrowed from the
Cabala. All the Masonic associations owe
to it their secrets and their symbols.
straightforward. There can be no doubt
about these issues. The true mason is
therefore not creed bound. Cannot say
he's a Christian or a Muslim or a Jew.
He realizes with the divine illumination
of his lodge that as a mason his
religion must be universal.
Christ Buddha or Muhammad the name means
little for he recognizes only the light
and not the bearer. He worships at every
shrine, bows before every altar, whether
in the temple, mosque or cathedral,
realizing with his truer understanding
the oneness of all spiritual truth.
That's manly palmer, the last keys of
Freemasonry. Can you see where World
Council of Churches could come in with
something like this?
Joining all the religions together. Can
does it start make a little sound, a
little ring a bell or whatever? Well,
let's continue. Five points of
fellowship. foot to foot, knee to knee,
breast to breast, hand to back, mouth to
ear. These are identical to those used
in the dudic right of witchcraft
and very similar to those used in other
rights such as the Gardinian Alexandrian
rights. Now, Alexandria, that's where
the occult knowledge was maintained. It
was maintained in Alexandrian and in
Rome. Everything else in between was
destroyed. We'll come to that a little
later. There where Christianity
flourished, it no longer exists. Islam
exists there.
And from Alexandria and later from Rome
emanated the new religion.
Passing a secret name or chant from
mouth to ear is ancient magical practice
reflected in the Hebrew word cabala. So
it's a secret religion. Now, why is the
King James Bible on the altar? Masonry
has nothing to do with the Bible. It is
not founded upon the Bible. For if it
were, it would not be masonry. It would
be something else. The digest of Masonic
law, page 207 to 209. So, it's not the
Bible. The Bible is there as a what? As
a symbol.
But what about God and his son Jesus
Christ? Humanity in toto then is the
only personal god. Here again we are
talking about highmasons revealing their
information. Humanity. Have you heard of
the humanist manifesto
and humanism in general?
Right. This is a fascinating quote from
morals and dogma.
I read this entire book. It's the most
heavy reading I've ever done in my life.
I wouldn't suggest anybody reads it.
It's such a pain in the neck. But
nevertheless,
the Bible is an indispensable part of
the furniture of a Christian lodge.
This isn't the original, this cursive
only because it is the sacred book of
the Christian religion. The Hebrew
pentatuk
in a Hebrew lodge and the Quran in a
Mohamadan one belong on the altar. And
one of these
and the square and the compass properly
understood are the great lights by which
a mason must walk and work.
Okay. Which one?
Which one of the three is the great
light? Well, you have three choices. It
could be the Bible. It could be the
Pentatik. Or it could be the Quran.
I won't reveal it to you tonight, but
it'll get clear which one it is.
Masonry teaches that redemption and
salvation are both the power and the
responsibility of the individual mason.
Saviors like Hyramabef, they have a
ritual where they go through the raising
of Hyramabe
can and do show the way. But men must
always follow and demonstrate each for
himself his power to save himself to
build his own spiritual fabric in his
own time and way. Every man in essence
is his own savior and redeemer for he
does not save if he does not save
himself he will not be saved.
All right, now it's getting a little bit
clearer. Do we need Jesus Christ in all
of this? Not really.
The Masonic author Pearson admits the
Masonic legend stands by itself
unsupported by history or other than its
own traditions. Yet we reci recognize
readily recognize in Hyramab.
This is the one who is symbolically
raised from the dead when a mason in his
ritual is called out of the coffin to
rise up and uh receive new life. We
recognize Osiris of the Egyptians,
the Mitras of the Persian, the Bakus of
the Greek, Dianius of the fraternity of
the artifice and Atis of the Friians
whose passion, death and resurrection
were celebrated by these people
respectively.
So in other words, the ancient religion
which counterfeeded the religion of
salvation in Jesus Christ is the
religion of masonry. So, it's the old
pagan religion which has another deity.
Now, how do we know if all of these have
the exactly the same ritual that Jesus
went through? How do we know which one
is right? The answer is the book of
Daniel
in chapter 8 and N give the precise time
when the Messiah would be born and the
circumstances.
And that is why the Jews have placed a
curse on anyone who numbers the 70 weeks
because then you would find out who the
real Messiah is. So none of these could
qualify for a messiah because none of
them had been predicted to the letter.
So if we look at their symbolism, you
will find it there. You will find the
obelix which is a symbol of the male
organ of Osiris which got lost when he
was disseminated. and Isis put him
together and built the missing piece.
Well, let's not go into too much detail.
Anyway, she did manage to get pregnant
by it and give birth to Horus. So, here
we have the Egyptian. You will see here
that the Torah, the Ten Commandments,
you'll see candlesticks. You'll see
pyramids. You'll see Egyptian worship.
You will see sun worship. All of it in
their symbolism. Here is a ritual of the
raising of Hyram Mabif. Here is the
book, the history of Freemasonry.
And you'll notice the symbol over there
at the top, the allseeing eye, which is
also the symbol of the Jesuits. Remember
in the previous lecture, we showed that
the Jesuit order created Freemasonry
wrote its rituals. And we gave all the
quotes. Everything has been done. You
can look it up in the previous lecture.
So, I'm not going to go into that
detail. Here are some of the symbols
that they use. And uh we can look at
some of them. The symbols come to have
two meanings.
Remember everything we're using here is
a bonafeder quotes.
The esoteric and the exoteric. The
esoteric meaning was the true or
original meaning understood only by a
few
and closely guarded by them. The
exoteric meaning that's for the goyam,
for the cattle, for the stupid ones, the
uninitiated,
was the invented or modified explanation
intended for the many. The sacred mis
mysteries which are often mentioned in
connection with many ancient religions
and which were closely guarded by the
initiate concerned esoteric meanings in
the religions of previous times. These
sacred mysteries were often
were merely continuations of the simpler
forms of the early sex worship carried
on by a select few.
Well, in the previous lecture we saw
rituals going on where people today
gather naked in forests
and that includes the presidents of the
countries that rule the world today.
Okay. And we saw that in the previous
lecture. Nothing has changed.
Our Masonic Masonic initiates misled.
What about poor Mason himself?
Let's go to the best source in the
world, morals and dogma, page 819.
The blue degrees. That's the first three
degrees of Freemasonry.
But the outer court of the portico of
the temple. Part of the symbols are
displayed there to the initiate. But he
is, will you note this, intentionally
misled by false interpretations.
It is not intended that he shall
understand them, but it is intended that
he shall imagine he understands them. No
wonder they don't give this book to the
lower initiates. That would freak them
out, right?
Their true explication is reserved for
the adepts, the princes of masonry. The
whole body of the royal and sacred art
was hidden so carefully centuries since
in the high degrees. There you have it.
Only the high degrees know what is going
on. This is the horse's mouth. Nobody
can argue with that. I've had many
masons be very angry with me, but in the
end, they've had to admit this. This is
the real McCoy. This is it.
I know many many masons who have become
good Christians as a consequence of
these lectures. So they are important.
There are many many people that belong
to the Masonic fraternity. Many many
people.
Masonry, like all the religions, all the
mysteries, hermeticism and alchemy,
conceals its secrets from all except the
adepts and sages or the elect, and uses
false explanations and
misrepresentations
of its symbols to mislead those who
deserve only to be misled. Basically
stupid. We're just using you to conceal
the truth
which it calls light from them and to
draw them away from it. Truth is not for
those who are unworthy or unable to
receive it or would pervert it. So
masonry jealously conceals its secrets
and intentionally leads conceited
interpreters astray. Morals and dogma
page 104 105.
There you have it. Straight from the
horse's mouth. Here's a highmason book
in Germany.
And uh it tells us there exactly what
they do. A Freemason, this is what
stands there, formed out of the
materials of his lodge. Behold, a master
mason rare, whose mystic portrait does
declare, the secrets of Freemasonry fair
for all to read and see, but few there
are to whom they're known, though they
so plainly here are shown.
So this is a language that you have to
learn. They created this language
because God confused the languages. So
they created a language in symbolism
that God would not be able to confuse in
future. That's their logic. Now let's
have a look at some of the symbols and
see where we get. Crossed swords are
part of the symbols. Corucopia,
the horn of plenty. We have pentagrams
and uh compasses and set squares and G's
which they say stand for God but
actually stands for generative
principle.
It's the male organ. Sorry. And the
female one because that's the only way
you're going to generate. This stands
for the masculine. This stands for the
feminine.
Now, if you go back into the other
religions, if you go to east to China,
for example, and you look at the the sun
god, so the equivalent in other words of
Isis and Osiris, you will find that they
are here. They are fy and noir. There
they are on their cave drawings. Here
they are. And you will note that fuksy
and noir carry the compass over there
and the set square. They are symbols of
the male and female deities. That's what
it stands for. So the cathedrals of the
world as was just interesting. This one
was being repaired. And of course who
would repair it? The companies. But what
does that tell us?
What kind of company would it be? It's a
masonic company. Right here you have the
apron. And the apron has various symbols
on it. You will see there the sun and
the moon with the stars around it and
the compass and the set square. And of
course hidden in here there is the
mystic letter M.
And uh that is the sigma on its side.
But uh masonry of course starts in every
single language in the world. Masonry
starts with an M.
Well, we don't go all through all the
details. I just want you to recognize
some of them. The keys are very
prominent. You'll find them in the
religious systems. Mystic towels are
very prominent. Uh pigeons with olive
leaves in their in their mouth. The path
symbol. All of this symbolism comes from
masonry.
And uh hammers and sickles are part of
the symbolism of Freemasonry. You know
where that occurred, don't you?
And uh here you can set this uh set
square either in the sickle form or in
the other form. The allseeing eye of
course the pentagram and the pentagon
very prominent. These are occult
symbols. Today we have whole buildings
that are built like pentagons. You know
that.
And then you have of course the figure
of the Johanssonite the St. John, the
so-called one, was really a symbol of
something else. And it has the X and
then it has the cross. What do you
notice about that cross? It's an upside
down cross. Symbol of victory over Jesus
Christ. Now, we'll come to some other
details about that in a moment. So,
hammers and sickles and upside down
crosses and G's and all kinds of
interesting things. Sun, moon, stars,
all this symbolism.
If you go to the tracing boards, first
degree, second degree, and so forth.
There's a vast amount of symbolism here.
Sun, moon, and stars. If you inculate
those, then you get hexogs, pentagrams.
Uh the star is in the east. To the
uninitiate, it is in he's informed that
it is the star of Bethlehem. But there's
of course a problem. If you just think
logically, the mi came from the east and
they walked towards the star. So where
was the star of Bethlehem? It was in the
west. So this is another one that was in
the east. And the Bible condemns the
praying towards the east, right? Because
that represented the sun god. And this
star in the east is none other star than
Sirius, the brightest star in the
heaven, the luminary, the illuminated
one, is the symbol of Lucifer. The
brightest planet in the in the heavens
is which one?
Is Venus.
Venus. It's called the morning star. In
the morning star name, it is masculine.
As Venus, it has a female deity name.
It's female. So, you have the male and
the female connotation right there. The
black and white squares represent
knowledge of good and evil. Now, man has
become as one of us, knowing good and
evil. And so, we can continue right
through all the symbolism. We don't have
time to go into it all. The two pillars
Yakim and Boaz supposedly the temple of
Solomon's temples pillars but these are
representations of the zigarut of
Babylon
serpents encircling rings and globes and
issuing from globes are common in the
Persian Egyptian Chinese and Indian
monuments. Vishnu is represented suppose
reposing on a coiled serpent. So many of
their symbolism refers to the ancient
deities. The serpent with a tail in the
mouth is the universal serpent, the
lifegiver. The serpent is the symbol and
prototype of the universal savior who
redeems the world by giving creation the
knowledge of itself and the realization
of good and evil
manly palmer 33°reemason.
So it is the serpent that gives you a
knowledge of good and evil and he is the
one who is deified. You'll see skulls
and babies representing life and death,
cycles of life and death. It's
reincarnation. It sees forwards and
backwards. Often these are half white,
half black, representing the knowledge
of light and the knowledge of darkness.
And whether you worship the dark side or
whether you worship the light side
doesn't really make any difference. That
is why it is interesting that the light
side worshippers are known as
Luciferians and the dark side are known
as witches, wizards and satanists and
they are the best of friends because the
deity is the same. It doesn't matter
which vehicle you use to get to know
him. It is the same deity. Cosmic keys
the answer to heaven and uh Hades. Pagan
religious symbols are also very common
in Freemasons. Athen earth cirrus Hermes
very common one that they use. All
Jesuit cathedrals will have the symbol
of Hermes. And of course masonry claims
that it uses hermetic rights. her maze,
son of maze, son of Ham if you like from
the very beginning. We haven't got time
to go into all the uh details. So
Jupiter, Mars, Mercury, all these
symbols represent deities.
Morals and dogma page 851, the 32nd
degree, this is the highest degree. The
hermaphroditic figure, there you have
him, male, female, is the symbol of the
double nature anciently assigned to the
deity. Now remember that the Knights
Templars also worship Bafomet who was a
Mafrodite, male, female
as generator and producer of Brah and
Maya and Osiris whatever we don't have
to go into all the details. So if we go
through Scottish right masonry, the 33rd
degree is known as sovereign grand
inspector general. It's an honorary
degree for the highest masons and uh you
have to be a high initiate to get into
that and then you get down sublime
sublime prince of the royal secret is
the 32nd and you go all the way down
down down down until you get down here
to the blue degrees which are enterments
printers fellowcraft and master mason
and you can go up all the way almost to
the top and never know what you're doing
never know what you're actually involved
There's a youth group in Freemasonry
which is called Demole. Isn't that
fascinating? That is the man who was
sentenced to death for spitting on the
cross and for committing sodomy and the
most profane things under the sun. But
that's the youth group. Isn't it
interesting that Billy Graham said that
the demise are the elite of the youth in
the world? Fascinating statement.
Knights Columbus, we've seen them with
their fasy eye, we'll come to that in a
later lecture again, which control the
the world political system, at least in
the United States. And uh the
the head of a lodge gets to the position
of worshipful master. The Bible says you
must call nobody master, let alone
worshipful master. This violates the
first commandment.
The headquarters of the Supreme Council
of Scottish Right Freemasonry, Southern
Jurisdiction, USA. This is what you have
on the front. You have the Sphinxes with
the serpents on the sides. And this is
known as the house of the temple on the
east side of Northwest 16th Street
between RNS Street in Washington DC.
This is where the Highmasons meet. The
entire cabinet of the USA will meet
there. Whether they are Democrat or
Republican makes no difference. That is
where the decisions are made.
This is a book no called the deadly
deception written by a man James D. Shaw
who was initiated into the highest
degree the 33rd degree and later uh
rescended and left it. 33rd degree
initiation ceremony. The oath is sealed
by drinking wine out of a human skull.
May this wine I now drink become a
deadly poison to me as the hemlock juice
drunk by Socrates, should I ever
knowingly or willfully violate the same.
A member dressed as a skeleton places
his arms around the candidate who then
states, "And may these cold arms forever
encircle me should I ever knowingly or
willfully violate the same."
Here are some of the symbols of
Freemasonry. These are the so-called
secret symbols. If you look at them,
you'll find some of them are very
interesting. We're not going to go into
all of them. Let's enlarge some of them.
If you thought that had something to do
with Forkswven, I suggest you think
again.
Those are the two V's, one inside the
other, representing the union of the two
deities. And if you thought that was the
heart of the Union Jack, then you will
know now that the Union Jack means that
Great Britain is a Masonically
controlled country. So is its religion.
As we will see, these are all symbols of
uh this is Aquarius, for example. If you
thought that was the star of David, then
ask yourself why before masonry was
around, there was no star of David.
And these symbols over here, of course,
very, very prominent. We haven't got
time to go into all of these. We're just
opening it up. So, if you find ecstasy
and mandre tablets being distributed
amongst the youth, they will have all
these symbols on them. You thought that
was Mitsubishi
symbol? Well, they would be very upset
if you thought that they u helped to
propagate Mandra and ecstasy and the
like. And there you have this symbol,
this VW
symbol, this W that is uh two V's locked
inside each other. No, these are occult
symbols. In other words, these drugs are
being dispensed by an organization that
uses the symbols of its religion. And if
you thought that this papal choir choir
was sponsored by folks vahen, you have
better think again. That symbol means
something else on these innocent little
children that are bearing luciferian
symbols. Here is Alistister Crowley's
symbolism. You'll see it's very similar.
We'll have the pentagram and all the
other symbols over there. The G. Uh you
will notice that that is basically the
basic structure and you can fill it in
and then you can have a pentagram. You
can have it the that way around or you
could have it the other way around
depending on which you wanted. That
would be the goat of mendus. That would
be the dark side also. Unfortunately,
sorry ladies, the female side and that
would be the male representation. Let's
ask the dictionary of mysticism to tell
us what this means. The pentagrams
considered by occultists to be the most
potent means of conjuring spirits. When
a single point of the star points
upward, it is regarded as the sign of
the good and it means to conjure
benevolent spirits. When a single point
points down and a pair of points on the
top, it is the sign of the evil Satan
and is used to conjure up powers of
evil. That's what it says. It's
interesting that this symbol is of
course used everywhere in the world,
including most of the flags. Let's ask
another source. Encyclopedia of
Freemasonry. You won't get a better
source than that. Freemasons of the
United States have bacid consent. Refer
to it the pentagram as a symbol of the
five points of fellowship. So it's the
pentila of Pythagoras. The science of
the margi. The pentafula is called the
holy and mysterious pentagram. It's the
star of the magicians. So this is
occultism. Got it all over your flags.
Very interesting. Double triangles and
so forth.
You have male, female, good, evil, Adam,
Kadmon, all these symbols, a divine man.
And now we get to the point where we
start revealing what they actually mean.
And may God help us as we continue along
this road and find out what the hidden
agenda of this Freemasonry actually is.
We're now going into the actual teaching
of cremation. We've just looked at the
basic framework.
Notice this statement. It is far more
important that men should strive to
become Christs than that they should
believe that Jesus was
Christ. That's pretty straightforward.
The Catechism of the Catholic Church,
this particular one, this is the
Catechism of the Catholic Church, New
York Image Books, 1995, page 129,
says the following. For the son of God
became man so that we might become God.
The only begotten son of God wanting to
make us sharers in his divinity assume
assumed our nature so that he made man
might make men gods.
Marvel and rejoice. We have become
Christ. Now not all public catechisms
will have this. So don't look for it in
your general catechism. It's that
edition which says it because there's an
inner teaching and an outer teaching.
Don't forget that
Manly Palmer Hall 33°ree Freemason says
man is God in the making.
Hinduism teaches this that through your
various incarnations and Buddhism
teaches it that eventually through
Nirvana you become one with the divine.
You are divine.
Uh, another Masonic writer writes, "Be
still and know that I am God, that I am
God, the final recognition of the all in
all, the unity of the self with the
cosmos, the cognition of the divinity of
the self." So, this is the opposite of
what the Bible teaches in the beginning.
Sin would lead to death, but the serpent
said, "You will surely not die. You
shall be like God."
So, this is serpent language. This is
not God language. This is Lucifer's
teaching. This is not God's teaching.
The perfect man is Christ
and Christ is God. This is the
birthright and destiny of every human
soul. JD Buck, Mystic Masonry. Notice
the symbolism again. You could get the
hexog out of it and you could get that
sign out of it. You can turn it around
and put it in front of a car as well if
you like.
A triangle with a point down represents
the deity and is called the deity's
triangle or the master triangle. With a
point up, it is called the earthly
triangle, pyramid triangle or the fire
triangle. And this emblem symbolizes the
perfect or divine man. So when a
religion uses these triangles
in cabalism, they are saying we are
divine. So the star of David is a in
yourrface God. We are divine.
That's a terrible statement I'm making
here tonight. That's a terrible
statement.
With a point upwards, the equatorial
triangle stands for Shiva, the
destroyer, and signifies the flame which
rises upward from the funeral p towards
heaven. The symbol is familiar to us,
the Masons, in several degrees, notably
the 30th degree. Notice the higher
degrees be get initiated into what is
going on. This is ward freemasonry and
the ancient gods. So Shiva is the god
who is there represented. We'll come to
that in a moment. So when you see a
symbol like this, it's not as simple as
it sounds. This is Kilborn Platt showing
that Ohio historical markers, these
states are all dedicated masonically.
The double-headed eagle we've dealt with
already. The 32nd degree makes the
double-headed eagle its particular
emblem. And of course also of the 33rd
degree in this sign we conquer is what
it says over here. The Maltes cross also
the crown with the cross in it are
masonic symbols and you will find it is
the symbol of many churches particularly
Pentecostal churches. Then you have
various commasonry degrees. For example,
this is the symbol used by the order of
the eastern star which is female
Freemasonry which is of course run by
male Freemasonry. Freemasonry generally
is a white brotherhood but co-masonry
accommodates females and black people.
So to the uninitiate it seems as if the
white race is supreme once you get to
the higher initiates there is a
different story. and Nimrod was
worshiped as black or white. There is
chaos created between the races. So you
have the Klukluke's clan which is anti-
uh black and you have organizations
which are equally anti-white. This is
called dlectic thinking. Remember the
Hegelian principle. you create friction
between the races so that you can have
synthesis in the end and bring about a
new world order. So in order to unite
the races, the best thing to do is to
create chaos amongst the racists until
the pain of separation exceeds the pain
of unity. You understand the Hegelian
dialectic thinking? It's brilliant. It's
sick, but it's brilliant. And it doesn't
matter if you sacrifice hundreds of
thousands of lives to achieve your
objective because the end justifies the
means. It really is a terrible doctrine.
So if we go to co-masonry, this is the
symbol of uh co-masonry.
Are the symbols, words and other masonic
expressions also found within the
occult? Yes, they are. They also used in
the Golden Dawn and other societies
as we say. Here is the Order of the
Eastern Star. Here is their main center,
the International Headquarters, also
known as the International Temple. That
is where it is in Washington DC. This is
Prince Hall Freemasonry. This is Black
Freemasonry.
And very often the Masons themselves do
not know about all these
suborganizations.
So if you go up the ranks of um prince
hall freemasonry then you'll find
knights templars up there for example
knight templar well that tells you
something right so they really use these
names these are their this is their own
uh page so this is not something that
has been thought up and the very very
highest individuals in the black world
for example are prince hall freemasons
might I mention a name Nelson Mandela if
you're interested.
This is what they look like. So, there's
no such thing as it just being a white
brotherhood, although each one of the
groups is individually uh often
non-informed.
This is the the levels. These are the
levels in Freemasonry and we can fill
them in. The the actual levels vary
according to the source. This one here
is as it was revealed by A Rand who was
the girlfriend of uh Philip Rothschild.
Uh she committed suicide. Humanism is
the lowest level. Masons no aprons, the
YMCA, the whole scout movement out
there,
etc. forms part of Masonic
organizations. Rotary, the Lions, the
Oddfellows. Well, you have them right
next door. The lions. The lions of
course use the two-headed lion. That's
the two-headed one. All those symbols.
And these are all good organizations
that appear to do very good things. Blue
Masons, that's John's Masons. There you
have the name John again. Get very
nervous when you hear it. Yorkright.
Scottish right. Communism. Benberit.
Jewish masonry. Council of 500. Council
of 33. Council of 500 also known as the
Bilderberers if you like. The council of
13. And at the highest level we saw that
the papacy is involved because the
Jesuits control all of them every single
level. Here is the pope in front of the
boy scout movement and this is the
feeder organization into other
organizations and none of them know
anything about it. So don't accuse them
but have a look at some of their
symbolism and see if you find the
masonic symbolism there. You'll find it
female Masons that were very prominent
of course Helena Petrovna Blavatzki
founder of the Theosophical Society
Annie Basant Alice A Bailey and Alice A
Bailey her husband was foster he was a
32 degree Freemason and uh part of
co-masonry they started a publishing
company known as Lucifer Trust which
they later changed to Lucus Trust. This
is Elena Petrovna Blavatzki. This one
over here is Annie Ellis A. Bailey. And
these are the ones who wrote down
the secret of the secret doctrines. Of
course, once they achieved the highest
degrees, then they would have to be
male. So, Annie Basant is known as
brother Annie Basant, 33 degree
Freemason. The same in the Egyptians. If
a if a female pharaoh became pharaoh
then she was male. So hatepsuit for for
example is figured with a beard because
you had to be an honorary male. You
can't be the reincarnation of the sun
god if you're a female.
So co-masonry
Annie Basant and all these highmasons
Alice A. Bailey high priestess of the
new age movement received messages from
a Tibetan known as Dwal. On her
writings, you will find of course the
Masonic symbols and these are her
writings and of course uh Blavatzki is
the one who wrote Isis Unveiled uh
Secret Doctrine and all of these mystic
Masonic books which are virtually
impossible to get hold of although these
days you can if you search find them.
Let me take you to one of the largest
lodges in the world which has become a
museum. This one is in Gatri in
Oklahoma.
We'll go inside. You will see swastikas.
They will say they are the other way
around. Yes, that might be so. But that
doesn't mean anything because the one
way around it represents the female
aspect and the other way around it
represents the male aspect. So it
doesn't make any difference. Uh you will
find the symbol of the sun god Ra.
You'll find the allseeing eyes and then
you'll see this statue. It can be male,
it can be female. It makes no
difference. You should figure that out
by now. With the finger on the mouth and
they will tell you that means secrecy.
Don't reveal the secrecies or quiet in
the lodge. All kinds of nonsense they
will tell you. It's got nothing to do
with it. This is only for the initiate
to know what this is with. This is this
is the symbol of Horus and I'll show it
to you in a moment. On the floor you
have uh the various pentagrams in this
uh form over here and the pentagons and
in front of this statue it says all who
stand here stand facing the east. Let
each reviewer his obligation and renew
them in his heart. So this worship is
towards the east which the Bible
forbade. Now there's the god Horus. You
will notice that he's always depicted
with his finger on his mouth. His
religion is for the initiate. These are
the uh the the dress of the various
masonic levels. The sovereign grand
commander has this symbol on the front.
And there you have it on sovereign grand
commander Henry Clawson. That it is
that's the symbol of Buffett. That's
Baffomet
the androgenic god. And you will be
surprised where buffmet features these
days. I will be showing it to you in
future lectures. And of course, it's
also on the building over here which is
the headquarters of the mother supreme
council of the world, Washington DC,
where the constitution for the new world
order has already been written right
there.
That's buffomet. And this is how the
symbolism was also used by Alice A.
Crowley. In the lodge, you will find
IHS. I showed you that was the symbolism
for the Jesuit order ISIS horror set. Uh
this stained glass window in the in the
light it is uh in the day it is white in
the night it becomes black. A very
special technique and if you know that
Osiris was worshiped as black or white
then that explains the story. They have
an Egyptian room uh with all the
symbolism that goes along with it. They
have an Assyrian room because they
represent all the ancient religions.
Here is a statue of Albert Pike. It's
called the Albert Pike Lodge number 162.
To study and seek to interpret correctly
the symbols of the universe is the work
of the sage and the philosopher. It is
to decipher the writing of God. Albert
Pike. Now, here is his book, Morals and
Dogma. I've scanned this in so that
people don't say I'm talkingay. They
must know I have the book.
And uh whatever is quoted over here
comes directly from him. In the Scottish
right, the crown and scepter symbolize a
man's dominion over himself. We are God.
We don't need anyone else to tell us
what to do. The history of man's thought
is the only history worth much study.
Don't worry about the other one. There's
the library. I just photographed it to
show you that the history of Freemasonry
and the Encyclopedia of Freemasonry are
genuine uh books. The New Age has
magazine has been replaced by Scottish
Wright magazine. There's also the symbol
over there that we spoke about earlier.
And it is to himself alone that man can
find enduring happiness. We are our own
savior. Again in this lodge you will
have Jacqu de mole um honored roacianism
the cross on the rose the one who really
suffered was Osiris not Jesus Christ and
uh there you have the mystic towel
and other symbolism like the lion with
eagle wings symbol of Babylon and here
you have the double-headed eagle in its
original black white form representing
the two deities. This is the cornucopia.
What does it stand for? It is the symbol
of many political organizations.
It was the symbol of the organization
that expanded and used apartheite. It
was the symbol of the national party in
southern Africa.
It's interesting.
So what were they? Let's ask what the
carnicopia means. The carnicopia or horn
of plenty was double sexed in symbolism.
The horn was masculine and the inside
was feminine. The fruit inside
symbolized productiveness of the female.
It's a sex symbol again the union of
Isis and Osiris. So when we look at
these deities remember that's Horus
Isis. She's the one who stands on the
serpent. Mary is the one who stands in
Catholicism on the serpent. Dionius as
child is just the same thing. These gods
came in the hexog in the hexagon uh etc.
They came in the square. This is the god
Harpocratus or if you like
Horus. There he has the cornucopia in
his hand and the finger is broken off
that points to the mouth. As per usual,
here's another Masonic lodge. Inside
you'll have the same symbolism. You'll
have yin-yang signs up against the
ceilings. This is the blue room. And uh
there are only three lights in a lodge
because the north is the place of
darkness. Now if you know your Bibles,
you will know that the north is where
the throne of God is. That's the source
of darkness.
Something's upside down and the various
rooms used by the Scottish right and the
York right etc. Two pillars always
representing uh Yahim and Boaz. On top
of it, you'll see the signs of the
zodiac. And there they are. This uh
shows you what this is. Astrology is a
science demanding respect of the scholar
notwithstanding its designation as a
black art. And in a reflective sense, in
an occult science, this science was
known to the ancients as the divine art,
encyclopedia of Freemasonry. So
astrology is uplifted by Freemasonry.
Although the Bible condemns it right
from that science many of the most
significant emblems are borrowed. The
lodge itself is a representation of the
world. It is adorned with the images of
sun, moon and stars. And we can go
through the astrological symbols and see
that they represent phallic worship as
well. Made prominent part of the
mysteries. These are all masonic
sources. Here is another the the red
room freemasonation initiation
ceremonies we saw are identical to how
Lyola presented himself to the pope. So
they come directly from the Jesuit
rituals. Some of the uh pomp and
grandeur of the lodge you will find
represented in the parliaments of the
world. Uh the symbolisms this one is
very prominent and uh you will see many
organizations use it. sports people use
it. Why? Because the sports companies
and the sports superructures are all
masonically controlled and uh some of
the hand signals. We're not going to go
into that. We're going to stick to
quotes. Now, let's ask them directly.
We've seen it in symbolism. We've seen
it suggested. You can figure it out if
you're really interested, but uh most
people don't actually get there. So
let's ask at the higher degree degree
level. Tell us directly who do you
worship?
Who is the god of masonry? Elifi Levi,
mystery of magic. What is more absurd
and more impious than to attribute the
name Lucifer to the devil? That is to
personify evil. The intellectual Lucifer
is the spirit of intelligence and love.
It is the paraclee, the advocate. Isn't
that interesting? It is the Holy Spirit
where the physical Lucifer is the great
angel of universal magnetism.
So Lucifer is the Holy Spirit. Lucifer
is the paracletos. He is the advocate.
The Bible says we have one advocate and
that is Christ Jesus.
Lucifer represents life, thought,
progress, civilization, liberty,
independence. Lucifer is the logos,
the word, the serpent, the savior. This
is secret doctrine by Lena Petrovna
Blavatzki pages 17125
255 volume 2. I have them at home. If
you don't want to believe me I send you
a photocopy. It is Satan who is the god
of our planet and the only god. These
are pretty direct quotes. You won't get
round them. Let's go to Albert Pike
directly. Third degree degree Freemason.
Lucifer is the lightbearer. Strange and
mysterious name to give to the spirit of
darkness. Lucifer the son of the morning
is it he who bears the light and with
its splendor intolerable blinds feeble
sensual or selfish souls doubt it not so
who's the god of freemasonry Lucifer
Albert Pike morals and dogma the devil
is the personification of atheism or
idolatry for the initiate it's not a
person but a force do you know a movie
where they say the force be with you I
know a movie like that the Bible says
and no marvel for Satan himself is
transformed into an angel of light to
Corinthians. Now, let's get into the
nitty-gritty. This is the instruction to
the 23 supreme councils of the world
given in 1889. And it reads as follows.
Albert Pike, the head of Scottish
Freemasonry and the founder of their of
of of that Bible of Freemasonry.
That which we must say to a crowd is,
"We worship a God, but it is the God one
adors without superstition." To you,
sovereign Grand Inspector's General,
take note of this quote. I'm going to go
a bit slower here. To you, sovereign
grand inspectors general, we say this,
that you may repeat it to the brethren
of the 32nd,
31st, and 30th degree. Notice it says
may. It doesn't mean that they do. It
means you may.
32nd, 31st, and 30th degree, the Masonic
religion should be by all of us
initiates of the high degrees be
maintained in the purity of the
Luciferian doctrine.
If Lucifer were not God, would Adonai,
that's the other one, that's Jesus if
you like, whose deeds prove his cruelty,
pitify, and hatred of man. He brought
the flood. He destroyed Sodom and
Gomorrah. That lovely peace, loving
oldtime San Francisco. He just destroyed
it. Can you believe that? And his
priests culminate, yes, Lucifer is God.
And unfortunately, Adonai is also God.
Because light cannot exist without
darkness. Blah blah blah blah. So
question,
at which level should a mason know who
he's worshiping?
The 30th, the 31st, the 32nd, and the
33rd degree. A 33 degree Freemason will
know who he worships. Yes or no? Is that
clear? Okay. Now, what if I could show
you who the 33deree Freemasons of this
world are? Would that change your
opinion from one wow what a wonderful
achievement to oops there's something
wrong here yes or no
is that do you think that is important
what if you were to find out that the
greatest preachers in the world are
33deree Freemasons how would you react
how would you react if you found out
that the politicians of the world are
33deree Freemasons the highest
politicians in the world how would you
react would it change your perception
somewhat
The true name of Satan, the cabalists
say, is Yave reversed.
For Satan is not a black god, but the
negation of God. For the initiates is
not a person, but a force. Albert Pike,
morals and DMA, page 102.
To conceive of God, the Cabala imagined
him to be a most occult light. Albert
Pike, morals and dogma, page 740.
Here is a conjugation addressed to
Emperor Luca. Emperor Lucifer, master
and prince of the rebellious spirits, I
adure thee to leave thine abode and
whatever quarter of the world it may be
situated and come hither to communicate
with me.
When the m When the mason learns that
the key to the warrior on the block is
the proper application of the dynamo of
living power, he has learned the mastery
of his craft, the seething energy of
Lucifer in his hands. And before he may
step onward and upward, he must prove
his ability to properly apply energy. He
must follow in the footsteps of his
forefathers, Tubalcain. It's an
interesting name. We haven't got time to
go into all those details. Who with the
mighty strength of the war god hammered
his sword into a plowshare. So you first
create war and chaos
so that people will be willing to give
it up and join into one giant Luciferian
empire. Do you know what irritated the
devil most?
When God separated
the nations.
That was a headache to him. It gave him
four and a half thousand years of
headache. He's been battling for four
and a half thousand years to get his act
together again. He's got his act
together.
The devil is now called darkness by the
church. Notice to this is a quote from
Blavzky. This is you cannot get better
sources than this. This is secret
doctrine page 71. The devil is now
called darkness by the church. Whereas
the in the Bible is called the son of
God, the bright star of the early
morning, Lucifer. See Isaiah. They turn
everything upside down. I'll show you
why in a moment. There's a whole
philosophy of dogmatic craft in the
reason why the first archangel who
sprang from the depths of chaos was
called looks Lucifer the luminous son of
the morning or man vantric dawn. He was
transformed by the church into Lucifer
or Satan because he is higher and older
than Jehovah
and had to be sacrificed to the new
dogma.
So what the uninitiate gets
is the doctrine of the Bible washed down
and the initiate turns it upside down.
The devil is the true God and Jehovah
Yave is the bad guy.
Well, let's see if we can back it up.
Lavatzki's secret doctrine page 73.
Jehovah esoteric as Elohim is also the
serpent or dragon that tempted Eve. And
the dragon is an old glyph for astralite
prioral principle which is the wisdom of
chaos.
Okay. So the devil is the wisdom of
chaos. But the real bad guy was who?
Jehovah. So the Bible is turned upside
down. Now Jehovah tempted Eve and not
the serpent.
Blavatski secret doctrine volume two.
The philosophical system of the gnostics
and the primitive Jewish Christians. The
Nazarines and the Ebianites are fully
considered. They show the view held in
these days outside the circle of Mosaic
Jews about Jehovah. He was identified by
all the Gnostics with evil. So the
Gnostics believe that Jehovah is the bad
one, Lucifer is the good one. They are
Luciferians.
Secret doctrine volume one, the great
serpent of the garden of Eden and the
Lord God are identical.
So God is the serpent. He's the bad guy.
Turn it around. And so are Jehovah and
Cain. One, the Cain who is referred to
in theology as the murderer and the liar
to God. So who's the murderer and the
liar? Now Jesus is the murderer and the
liar and the serpent is the good guy.
Well, secret doctrine volume 2 page 388.
The Appalachian Satan Hebrew Satan, an
adversary from the word satana to be
adverse belongs by right to the first
and crulest adversary of all the other
gods. Jehovah, not to the serpent, which
spoke only words of sympathy and wisdom
and ease at the worst, even in the
dogma, the adversary of men.
This is serious stuff. Therefore,
Jehovah was called by the Gnostics the
creator of and one of the offenomorphs,
the serpent, Satan or evil.
Another one, we could go on and on and
on and on. He calls him a Jehovah
Frankenstein. That's not very nice.
Wouldn't you say so?
Calling my God Frankenstein.
The cabalists say that the true name of
Satan is Jehovah placed upside down.
I'll tell you something in the Islamic
lecture which will really excite you.
Satan is not a black god but the
negation of the white deity. Now black
and white has got nothing to do with
skin color here. It has to do with
illumination.
And so we could go on. I'm going to show
you something else that's interesting
here. Jehovah,
even the insider knows this. Jehovah
becomes Satan and Michael
and his army,
Satan and the rebellious angels.
So Mael, which means the one who is what
God is, is Satan and his angels.
H and Lucifer and his angels, he's
setting up his kingdom down here. My
Bible says Michael is the prince that
stands for your people and he will stand
up and come and sort the evil one out.
Right or wrong. So, we've turned the
doctrine upside down. Michael being
simply Jehovah himself, one of the
subordinate spirits at best.
They hate Jesus Christ.
Just like the Templars, they spit on the
cross. Now, if you do not believe the
Blavatsky source, let's go to morals and
dogma. The Masonic source. The deity of
the Old Testament is everywhere
represented as the direct author of
evil. There he says exactly the same
thing. I don't have to repeat it. Let's
carry on. So little have the first
Christians who despoiled the Jews of the
Bible understood the first four chapters
of Genesis in their esoteric meaning.
Now let's go into this that they never
perceived that not only was no sin
intended in the disobedience but
actually the serpent was the Lord God.
He himself who was as the offos the
logos the bearer of divine creative
wisdom taught mankind to become creators
in their term. The serpent was so good
to you.
You would be still stupid if it wasn't
for the serpent.
The devil is now called darkness by the
church, but the Bible calls him the son
of God. Remember that one. So no wonder
manly Palmer Hall 33°ree Freemason says,
"I hereby promise the great spirit
Lucifuge, prince of the demons, that
each year I will bring unto him a human
soul to do with as it may please him."
Do you think they might still have human
sacrifices?
And in return, Lucifu promises to bestow
upon me the treasures of the earth and
to fulfill my every desire for the
length of my natural life. Many palm,
you can have it.
I prefer Jesus Christ and eternal life.
Official logo of Ordoor Templar
Orientas. We don't have to go into all
these details. Who then is allowed to
know the truth about masonry?
We must create a super right. Now notice
carefully.
Which will remain unknown to which we
will call those masons of high degrees
that above whom we shall select with
regards to our brothers in masonry.
These men must be pledged to the
strictest secrecy.
Through this supreme right we will
govern all Freemasonry which will become
the one international center the more
powerful because its direction will be
unknown.
This was a letter from Pike to the head
of the order of the Illuminati Jeppo
Mini.
So who governs the world? A superite.
George Bush calls them a thousand points
of lights
illuminated ones. They don't use this
terminology for nothing.
They were going to create three world
wars.
There's the quote. I'm not going to go
into details on this quote right now.
There's a lecture coming up.
Revolutions, dictators, and wars. We'll
look at it then. Scary stuff. Ordo
is their statement. That means order out
of chaos. The symbol they use for that
is the furnex rising from the ashes.
Out of the destruction
of what God has put onto this planet,
Satan will create his diabolical kingdom
where all nations, all religions will
become one because that's the only way
he can have universal rulership.
Jesus says, "My kingdom is not of this
world."
Jesus says, "Come out and be separate."
They say, "Come in and be inclusive or
else."
Wow, it's getting interesting. There's
another lecture coming up. Don't miss
any of these. This is amazing stuff. If
you think that some have said to me,
"Ordo is not
a masonic
statement." I said, 'Excuse me, I've
been in the lodge and photographed their
documents. There it is, Ordoor Aba.
And if you want to know how we got in
there, we just walked in.
There are witnesses at the back that we
didn't do this clandestinely. I just
went in and I photographed it while my
wife was talking to someone and keeping
them busy. There it is. Ortoc,
this is the main lodge in England.
That's the main building. Now, you
weren't I wasn't allowed to take any
photographs inside. You can go into the
first portions. You couldn't go into the
others, but I showed you what it looks
like in one of the other lodges anyway,
so it doesn't make any difference.
Notice that the north is the place of
masonic darkness. The east is where the
worshipful master sits, representing
this androgenic principle. The south is
where the junior warden sits. The west
is where the senior warden sits. Then
there is an altar and there are three
masonic lights. These are the symbols
that you will find on the masonic lodge.
The compass, the set square, the
triangles, the allseeing eye, all of
these.
And uh
the allseeing eye, let's ask the
encyclopedia of Freemasonry what it
stands for. So when you see it on the
dollar, ask the horse's mouth who they
put it there. The all-seeing eye is an
all-important symbol of the supreme
being borrowed from by the Freemasons
from the nations of antiquity. On the
same principle, the Egyptians
represented Osiris, their chief deity,
by the symbol of an open eye and placed
the hieroglyphic of him in all their
temples. If it's the right eye, it's
masculine. If it's the left eye, it's
female. Doesn't really matter which one
it is. You have Isis and Osiris. That's
their own source. So that's what it
means on the dollar and it means nothing
else. It's the symbol that the Jesuits
claim as their main symbol. So all of
these symbols have an esoteric and an
exoteric meaning.
Now what does that represent?
That's the tower of Babel. Correct? Now,
as we said, Babel was an attempt to
unite all people in apostasy to God. And
what did God do?
He confounded the languages and gave us
another 4 and a half thousand years for
souls to accept him and be saved. What a
generous, kind God we have. If it wasn't
for that action which has confounded one
word of God, just one word. Imagine
this. One word.
And the devil had four and a half
thousand years of work. How strong is he
really? I don't think he has any
strength compared to God whatsoever.
He's a liar and he's been a liar from
the be beginning. and he could not do
what he wanted to do because God gave
his word and the word was spread abroad.
But the serpent out of the bottomless
pit was going to make war on the word.
Don't forget that. We're going to look
tomorrow and the day thereafter what he
did. Wow. Unbelievable.
So here is the Tower of Babel. This
comes from a Masonic source. Above there
is the all-seeing eye and here they are
measuring and building.
It's interesting that uh one of the
highest politicians in France said just
recently when they put a poster across
the whole of Europe of the temple of the
Tower of Babel with a crane on it under
construction, he said, "We are building
a new Babel and this time we will
succeed."
Well, we'll see. Well, let's ask the
high Freemasons, Arthur Edward Weight,
who wrote the Encyclopedia of
Freemasonry, by the way. He should know
what it means. Arthur Edward Weight, as
regards masonry, Babel, of course,
represented a masonic enterprise.
It is well known that the Tower of Babel
was one of the most ancient traditions
of masonry. There you have it.
I have said nothing tonight. Please note
every single statement I have made has
been substantiated from their own
highest sources.
So please don't say that I am presenting
things here which are divisive.
If you are angry,
get in contact with them, not with me. I
didn't say it. They said it. Every
single statement in the Masonic quiz
book, the question is asked, who was
Nimrod? The answer is he was the son of
Kush in the old constitutions referred
to as one of the founders of masonry. I
thought he was a warrior before the Lord
against the Lord.
and in the scriptures as the architect
of many cities. In the York manuscript
we find at the making of the Tower of
Babel there was masonry first much
esteemed of and Nimrod was a mason
himself and loved well masons.
So Mason is nothing other than a
harborer of the occult knowledge,
clothing themsself with
all their good deeds and their many many
members who they use maliciously and lie
to so that they might appear noble.
These people are wicked at the highest
level.
Masonic author Kenneth McKenzie
tells us that Hermes was also one of the
founders of masonry. her mis
they use the words like this like raes
for example son of rames
me means son of son of her her ham if
you like patrons
links Hermes and Satan together you have
to piece the puzzle together it's very
tricky to find out what masonry teaches
you have to go from one source to
another because no one author will tell
you everything. So let's piece it
together. So the one author says Hermes
is the one that's important to them.
Blavadski says Hermes is the god of
wisdom called Tat Tat set
Satan
and that he was furthermore when viewed
under his bad aspect Typhon of the
Egyptian Satan who was also set. So when
they say they have set that's Satan. If
they say Hermes that's Satan in his
Luciferian form doesn't matter could be
male female who cares one or the other.
Arthur Edward wait writes in regard to
masonry. Babel of course represented a
masonic enterprise and the early
expositors reaped full benefit from that
fact. They remembered that the people
who were of one language and one speech
journeyed from the east to the west like
those who have tried and proved as
master masons. When they reached an
abiding place in the land of Shina, it
affirmed that they dwelt therein as
Noahidai being first characteristic name
of masons. It was here that they built
the high tower of confusion. Out of evil
comes good.
Aha. So God was evil when he confused
the languages, but they will turn it
back to good. Have you got that?
And the way to achieve that is to rub
them up in chaos, destroy them, use them
as gun foder, kill them, do whatever you
like, make the pain of separation so
great that you will beg for unity. Have
you all got that?
Now, who are these? No, that's another
lecture. I mustn't digress. It was here
that they built the high tower of
confusion. Out of evil comes good.
However, and the confusions of tongues
gave rise to the ancient practice of
masons conversing without the use of
speech. So if you're going to confuse us
with languages, we'll use symbols. So
symbolism is a masonic language. Today
people tell me, "But the symbols are
everywhere."
Hello. What does that tell you? Who's in
control? Everywhere.
The druids of Britain and Gaul had a
deep knowledge concerning the mysteries
of Isis and worshiped her under the
symbol of the moon. The moon was chosen
for Isis because of its domination
over water. The Druids consider the sun
to be father and moon, the mother of all
things. See teachings of the ages. So
the Drews are the ones who control
Great Britain.
Winston Churchill belonged to the
Druudic order of Freemasonry and he was
a 33 degree Freemason and I photographed
his apron in case someone doesn't
believe that.
And so we start finding little tidbits
of history that make sense. As you enter
the lodge in England, you have to cross
the pentagram.
And if you look up,
you have this statue at the top. It's a
shield. And there's a chevron over
there. You see it? Let's make it a
little bit bigger. There it is. Chevron.
Chevron. Chevron. Do you find it on some
cars? Maybe just just for interest sake.
And then of course you have other
symbolism over here. And you have even
the ark of the covenant because he wants
to be like the most high, but he's
covering cherabs.
have got what kind of feet?
Goats feet.
This is Satanism.
That's why in masonry you ride the
goats. There are many jokes about riding
the goats. There are many fun postcards.
They make fun of it. They have the goats
singing hymns. They have the goat doing
this, riding the goat, this and that.
It's a symbol of Lucifer. We'll see
later that they say goats go to heaven.
sheep go to hell.
Interesting.
The Bible says in Ephesians 5:8-14,
"For you were once darkness,
but now you are light in the Lord. Live
as children of light, for the fruit of
the light consists in all goodness,
righteousness, and truth, and find out
what pleases the Lord." have nothing to
do with the fruitless deeds of darkness,
but rather
expose them. I think we did that
tonight. I don't want anything to do
with it, but to expose it is necessary.
For it is shameful even to mention what
the disobedient do in secret, but
everything exposed by the light becomes
visible. For it is light that makes
everything visible.
What a beautiful word of God we have. No
hidden agendas. Jesus says, "I have done
nothing in secret."
I love the God of the Bible. And the
mere fact that I am still alive shows
that God is almighty. What a wonderful
God we serve. What a kind God we serve.
I would not want to give up serving him
for
all the satanic wealth of this world.
What does it mean? It means nothing.
Jesus is coming soon and the kingdom of
darkness will have had his shot
and it will walk over the bloodstained
earth that it has marauded and tortured
for the centuries and centuries in wars
and battles.
But the word of God has remained through
all that time. The word of God stands
like a rock. the last thing that stands
in his way.
What a war he has fought against the
word of God. And I would like you to
come to the next lectures because we're
going to see what he has done
and it will be fascinating.
Fascinating. So, tomorrow night we're
going to talk about
what they did with the Bibles, the
battle of the Bibles.
Happy birthday.
Oh,
there.
glory.
Oh,
hey.
holy.